so you mentioned in
wrestling life that the brands brothers
looked up to uh royce alger who was
known
for pushing the limits of physical
wrestling but
not getting too rough so how do you find
the line between extreme
physical wrestling but at the same time
not
rough wrestling or angry wrestling so
that line
between aggression tough wrestling and
anger
well i think anger would cause
less successful wrestling i think anger
would cause you to
make mistakes and actually get out of
position
because i think anger is kind of a loss
of control
and there can be
a furious type of
attack
but i think if it crosses the line to
anger
then you're going to be vulnerable and
so
royce and the brands
wrestled to the edge through the edge
but when the whistle blew they stopped
and there's people that when the whistle
blows they keep going
it's like in a football game a fight
breaks out and it's after the whistles
blow
well when the whistle blew they they
backed off
so that whistle was
something that in a match
that that kind of gave them the
boundaries
but perhaps it could be a little bit of
fuel so in wrestling tough the book
that you just got from mike chapman uh
the new edition
talks about bill cole undefeated
northern iowa wrestler
and uh how he talked about
how my strength speed and ability to
think were increased tremendously
by just sitting apart from the action
prior to the match
and getting into a state of controlled
anger
so can anger trolling controlled
yeah so anger could be fuel as long as
it's controlled
right exactly you have that line one
side of the line you can have
an anger for performance and the other
side of the line
you if you go beyond that it's not going
to be for performance
it's going to be for not performance
because you're going to lose points
it's a fine line there's definitely a
fine line
you're talking about roy salger you're
talking about tom brands you're talking
about terry brands i mean you got world
championship titles there you got an
olympic championship title there
you got a world silver medalist in uh in
uh
and roy selzer and you know and that
that's
what when i talk to him about the world
silver medalist
he's haunted by that because he was
actually 20 seconds
away from winning when he got beat in
the end there but that's part of the
game
and it's i don't know whether he's
okay with it or not because he says
every after talking about things he goes
i'm okay with it now but then he keeps
talking about it
so i don't really think he's okay with
it
and i it's it's hard for him to actually
make amends
to himself when you really don't do it
i mean it's no matter what the situation
even with
the owings loss yeah it still eats it i
mean yeah i'm a world champion he's not
and he wanted to be i'm olympic champion
he's not
he wanted to be one of the greatest
coaches of all time
yeah yeah and so you know so he
you know it's like why do i keep going
back to it
because because you're not you don't get
over
those things so royce really keeps going
back to it even though he says he's fine
and he and but then he realizes he's
really not fine
because that's just the nature of the
game and that's why he was able to win
national titles and
and make uh world teams and and stuff
like that
uh you know even if what's interesting
about him he's analyzed
all the people that he's wrestled and a
lot of them have won world and olympic
championships
and he's beaten every one of them at one
time or another and he
didn't get to that world championship
gold or a limping gold
and that i i he says it because
they did it so he show he's showing
people that
that i beaten those guys yeah
but apparently he didn't beat him at the
right time
and so it still haunts him you don't get
away from that stuff
you